danil dendi ishutin was born in Laville
ukraine on December 30th 1989 the son of
a piano teacher his formative years were
full of music and dance although the
family didn't have much money with the
help of his grandmother they were able
to purchase a home PC in 1997 Dendy was
instantly captured by computer games
much like many kids his age Dendy
nurtured his love of gaming with
countless hours at the computer playing
counter-strike and Warcraft 3 to rise to
challenge fate and lead their brethren
sadly his father died of cancer when he
was still young and then he further
retreated into gaming devoting even more
time to the PC to cope with the loss
it's like destructible it was like his
time machine and let's maybe one of the
reasons I am playing no maybe I wouldn't
title as his skills improved he began to
participate and win some local Warcraft
3 tournaments gaining a thirst for
competition and a drive to be the best
eventually he would discover dota which
became his obsession he had taken his
first steps down the road to eSports at
only 17 years old Dendi quickly gained
notoriety within the DOTA community and
found his way into the competitive scene
as one of Ukraine's rising talents 2010
was the year that Dendi reached new
heights as he joined not has been Sara
on Christmas Day Dendi and Navi seemed
to be a destined match one of Ukraine's
most prestigious eSports organizations
picking up one of Ukraine's brightest
stars Navi didn't waste any time quickly
establishing themselves as one of the
best dota teams in the world but now the
other champion see what they were the
best team in the tournament
then valve changed everything the dota
scene was abuzz upon the announcement of
dota 2 and the first ever international
to be held during Gamescon 2011
speculation ran rampant with valve at
the helm the possibilities were endless
and a rumored prize pool of $50,000 was
more than enough to send the community
into a frenzy then the news came 16
teams fighting for 1.6 million dollars
the largest prize pool in eSports
history for most dota fans and players
it was a mind-blowing amount of money
and for Dendi and Navi it could be
life-changing already one of the
strongest teams in DotA na'vi received
an invite to TI but with so much on the
line and every single one of the best
teams from around the world there to
compete the
wasn't going to be easy oh he's having
fun we trying to like you trying to
scare me our opening line game find me
dendi and na'vi only dropped one game
the entire event place but now the other
champions tsunami they really think they
were the best team in the tournament
rendered a single famous when the dust
had settled na'vi had overcome teams
from russia denmark Singapore China and
more to claim the prize and there was no
doubt that they had earned their title
as the best dota team in the world the
money and prestige catapulted Dendi even
further into the spotlight
making him a worldwide sensation and the
community favourite
aside from fans loving his goofy
demeanour Dendi cemented his reputation
as an elite player with tremendous
individual skill and innovative picks
and builds he pioneered a build of for
staff and blink dagger on health just
about every hero and his signature Pudge
is legendary to this day battery assault
there was no half then be showing up
just as a south bounce on sharing with
the dragon flow he became firmly
established as not only the face of
na'vi but of the dota 2 scene with his
dota 2 career off to a flying start
Dendi didn't slow down even for a second
but that is going to be JJ I will leave
we'll leave the guys here you can see
the end school board as well just so
much fun for na'vi just everything going
their way na'vi and dendi's dominance in
the first full year of dota 2 was
without question five premier tournament
wins leading into the International 2012
marked them as a clear contender to
defend their title at the tournament
itself dendi and na'vi got off to a
mediocre start only managing a record of
eight and six in the group stage however
when it came to the main event na'vi
didn't disappoint now we have a second
best of three going the distance but we
decane and the defending champions Navi
and the entirety of DK is down and that
is a rampage for voids and the cranium
ah I think this is probably going to be
the most entertaining match of the day I
mean we've got again Navi I feel like
hungry you're on pace to play just a
series of amazing matches they took on
VK yesterday as we talked about a
phenomenal series now they're gonna be
taking on IG arguably a better team
cannot be bring the magic again two days
in a row maybe a desperate moment they
pulled off now iconic plays like the
play to keep hope alive and fight their
way to the grand finals not me this is a
team they have a lot of resilience
they're the original champs of dota 2 if
anybody can come back from this it's got
to be Navi I lead the way I believe it
should be though they're going to cut
for the shorter path they storm up the
river nation from those waiting in the
wig
Tommy is about to be caught is asleep
desert he catches everyone's bonus to be
a total disaster setting unit grab the
cut everyone the blends all twelve
planets
are you getting around for said what are
you that's why I to survive twice going
to go down I've rethought the puzzle
Naga gather and fly the bevin wasn't
because he said turn it around I don't
even know how to go through it standing
ovation from the crowd the last hour was
going down and I think Dendi dazzled on
Rubik puck and clean of pain throughout
the event building his legacy of big
performances however Navi would
eventually lose three two one to the
chinese powerhouse Invictus gaming in
the grand final three dead
gg-go gigi is called high GS a champion
they're going home with the million wild
undeterred by the result Dendi continued
to help make 2012 the year of Navi as
the team went six more tournaments in
the final three months however a new
year called for a new look on Navi
ars-art and light of heaven left early
in 2013 replaced by young talent funnik
and dendi's former KS international
teammate kuroky the revamp roster got
off to a rocky start putting up a mixed
bag of results the main obstacle to Navi
in 2013 was the rise of legitimate
threats to their dominance in the
European and CIS scenes while China had
primarily been na vi's main competition
until then teams such as fnatic EU
Empire and Alliance the latter of whom
would forge a dramatic rivalry with Navi
over the course of the year emerged to
push Navi harder than ever
central to Navi strategy was the
consistent play of Dendi who despite the
roster change was still a very strong
player and was a dominant 1v1 laner Oh
max oh I gonna not it first kill is a
gay however surging talent such as mushi
and s4 challenged and even surpassed
Dendi further placing strain on na vi's
usual game plan despite all these new
obstacles
Navi eventually found their feet towards
the back half of the year and entered
into ti3 winning three premier events in
a row
once again nabhi looks set to prove that
when push came to shove they were still
a force to be reckoned with when it came
to the International mentally though I
think novice Villa have because of the
success in the past yeah they they
definitely seem very comfortable right
now and Nobby I don't think they got to
be too shaky you have to remember
Navi over 2013 finished 12 tournament so
far
and 10 of them the first place now he
taught their group and ran the upper
bracket all the way to the UV finals
where they ran up against their dreaded
rival the nearly unstoppable Alliance
and went details are na g g a lion
what's together a two to nothing
blanking of knobbing after dropping that
series to no and falling into the lower
bracket where they narrowly overcame the
red-hot underdog orange esports club
na'vi
earned their second shot at alliance and
the grand finals it all comes down to
this two million dollars on the table
the rivalry already intense enough to
earn the moniker of dota el clásico here
came to its ultimate conclusion and the
series has gone down in history as one
of the best in dota twos illustrious
history the series got closer and closer
as it went on leading to the now
legendary Game five it's Game five of a
best of five Elias vs. Navi
dollars at stake he's going to find them
in but isn't public response form in but
as for just walked into a gang party
tears to relocate here we go Michael's
already go the kuroky strapping low oh
my god hit so hard a boat trying to find
a kill me while Teddy trying to focus on
that floor as more dives again surreal
ok goes back out slowness s words my
boss home whereas the fuscus ND and
dropping big Mel strike they're pulling
away with this game
Bonaparte falls off well dandy dandy
looking for more Navi looked on the
brink of winning it all but Alliance
outmaneuvered them to snatch away the
title and don't have nobody beat he
though he canceled defeat sake Robbie
it's not going to be back in the bank
he's not became me but no flutes of
travel they also sent a sepia Club
- bye - cause now they go over the
throne alliance rocky football play gave
me say one minute around thinking it
Dylan second hey you in the doll is when
pi3 Navi finished second at TI once
again unable to recapture their throne
despite being ever so close the loss
devastated the team Havas 2004 as -
angrily call some of his teammates
useless idiots on social media na'vi
continue to have moderate success for
the rest of 2013
and the early stages of 2014 but the
team wasn't quite as dynamic as they had
been and then DS dominance was waning
the rest of the world was catching up
and the game was far different than what
it had been until then both kids doomed
up but with tether still upon them
you'll get hex up overgrowth and focus
down huh both will fall kuroky shortly
thereafter 3-0 yeah they're just pretty
much let's make it do they focus
whatever they needed to on the tiny oh
it's like obvious really devastated by
the logical everybody's watchin it might
be in not be might be out here in the
quarterfinals here it is no one an 8 DG
DG will take the victory Navi it being
eliminated
and now he comes thinking that damage
out so expensive to hide the double kill
the things makes a triple kills the big
things my old truck ljj around
three finalists it's called the
International claw Tommy an early exit
and seventh place from ci4 with a clear
sign the winds of change are blowing
next few years were more of the same for
Navi while Dendi still occasionally
turned heads the team struggled and
rarely made deep runs at events they
tried everything including multiple
roster changes that saw them bringing in
veteran faces and rookie talent alike
but nothing ever seemed to click the
competition was simply too fierce for
Navi to keep up and even at his best
Dendi was struggling to match his
competition as the decline continued
Navi didn't receive an invite to the
international for the first time and
although they still managed to attend
ti5 via the qualifier they bond out of
the event in 13th to 16th this is a
second ok we're going to begin looking
for
[Music]
[Applause]
the cannibal live close up so it simply
break them sell yourself mate you can't
beat the game Oh
[Music]
mom be around CG gaming move forward
what an end to the game on October 16
2015
after failing to qualify for Valve's
first-ever major in Frankfurt
Navi released its entire dota 2 roster
however dendi's loyalty to Navi would
show through and he wouldn't give up the
team that had given him so much only
four days later Navi confirmed that
Dendi would return to the team and will
lead a rebuilt roster into 2016 while
the loss of his longtime teammate and
friend Havas was a blow to Dendi the
shake-up proved valuable as the team
performed well out of anyone and in a
while since their last starladder
victory fell short at the last
rotationally here they are Navi about to
take it mowing down pilot I hex it up
RTV bringing him down as well
Nobby they are doing it in style their
former captain will fall as well triple
kill particular ah and there's the call
Navi is truly back they have on their
first major tournament a very long time
they were once again qualifying for land
and even won the starladder i-league
star series season two over team secret
later in the year their first ever
significant win in over 20 months Dendi
had re-entered the public eye rekindling
the hope of his legion of fans around
the world a better showing at the Manila
major 2016 was encouraging already
foster Jeff doesn't have to buy back
flow device back with the only question
to Mako and it feels like this is how it
ends for a lion not with a bang
this is a whipper this is ugly haven a
Sun strike
santa clarita Wyatt wielding them down
this is not family-friendly at all and
there it is Gigi you give all Navi every
last one if their signature heroes but a
flop at ti6 was another dent in the
legacy of what had once been one of the
most successful TI performers of all
time behind on the cosmetic bats
humbleness disruption oh no the segment
humble man is back out with having me
John Doe target siren are they gonna be
able to get this Hill they're just going
to reset the fight but Oh with the BKB X
is a mountaintop a man will give himself
some fate and I'll be gonna have to take
them tell that of a whole year fixity
Roger etiquette presented with the her
name Bank not to be the case today go
these to be able to buy for only a
second extra general the only one to a
stake when he who will fall as Tommy
Holland the end of the game is
and they're run here while the recent
history of Dendy maybe one of struggle
uncertainty and disappointment it's also
one of unflinching loyalty dedication
and passion from the glory days until
today Dendy has never lost his
determination his drive or his smile no
matter the roster around him no matter
the situation then he pours his all into
every game even more than ten years
after his competitive debut this is what
makes him a dota legend and thankfully
his story is far from over
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]